the polish authorities are monitoring
the movement of people on the other side
of the border tracking migrants and
asylum seekers from the air the
government has drafted in thousands of
extra guards to fortify the nation's
defenses
but some have evaded the police and
military to make it across
polish police confirming that the body
of a syrian man has been discovered
close to the border
initial examination allowed us to
establish she was around 20 years of
agent from syria police in the process
of the examination have found a passport
however the examination from the police
the doctor and the prosecutor present
didn't allow us to establish the cause
of death
the man's body was found by a forestry
worker in woodland where other asylum
seekers are known to have died those who
make it into poland use the trees for
cover
aid agencies are prevented from going to
the border by the government but an
informal network of people have been
searching the woods they found dozens of
asylum seekers men women and children
many in a terrible state after spending
days and freezing nights in the woods
human rights activists chose the forest
to hold a press conference condemning
the behavior of the polish government in
refusing to allow people in
we failed as a country we are able to do
much more than this the polish
government is acting as if we were a
weak state and we are not we are able to
help these people
but poland is not alone among the
nations on the eu's eastern flank
determined to prevent people getting in
here lithuanian soldiers are seen
throwing bottles of water to a group
across the river but the country's
government like poland has reinforced
its military at the border both nations
accusing belarus of engineering a
humanitarian crisis
president alexander lukashenko has
responded to the eu threat of further
sanctions by warning he'll cut off
russia's gas supply to europe something
his ally vladimir putin didn't seem
entirely convinced
theoretically luka shenko as the
president of a transit country could
probably give the order to cataphar gas
shipments to europe although this would
be a violation of our transit contract
and i hope it will not come to this
this humanitarian and diplomatic crisis
is still evolving and caught in the
middle the thousands who were still
determined to make it to the european
union michelle clifford sky news poland